the government in Gaza says the Israeli
Defense Forces struck a hospital in the
center of Gaza City yesterday uh it was
I think it was in the afternoon it's
probably about 5:00 Eastern time here
suddenly the media and Twitter and
everything was blowing up that Israel
had bombed a hospital in Gaza uh of
course it has now turned out to be
completely untrue we're going to show
you a bunch of evidence of that uh but
here is Jake Tapper on CNN and I what do
I keep telling you about Jake the
problem with Jake Tapper is he's not
completely brain dead almost everyone on
CNN is completely brain dead or they're
a propagandist or a liar right almost
everybody Jake has this thing where
basically one out of every 10 things he
says is right or true like suddenly the
neurons fire he says something honest
and then everyone's like see Jake Tapper
is not that bad then he lies about nine
more things everyone's like screw Jake
Tapper then he says something fine as
opposed to just like put it out there
like either be horrible or just pick one
pick one you're driving everybody crazy
so here's Jake Tapper uh spewing pure
Hamas propaganda about a a a horrifying
Israeli War crime major story developing
right now in Gaza what the Palestinian
government is calling a war crime the
government in Gaza says the Israeli
Defense Forces struck a hospital in the
center of Gaza City Al Ali Baptist
Hospital preliminary estimates from the
government in Gaza put the number of
killed in the strike somewhere between
two and 300 we expect there are many
more innocent people still trapped under
the r the IDF says they're looking into
reports of the incident it remains
unclear to them right now they say if
the hospital was struck by Israeli war
planes or by a failed Hamas rocket
launch let's go straight to CNN's
Clarissa Ward who is in Israel in the
town of ashalon
Clarissa yeah Jake uh we have heard
non-stop Sirens basically for the last
few hours that in response to this horri
Ying strike on this alah Baptist
hospital that is a hospital in Gaza City
that is in the northern part of The
Enclave uh thousands of people were
taking shelter there from the continued
violence many people were being treated
there some of them couldn't be moved
despite evacuation orders that have been
in place and as you mentioned we are
hearing initial estimates of at least
two to
300 people killed in that strike and
many many many more feared dead now
Hamas is calling this a genocide that is
not journalism Jake Tapper what you are
doing is acting as the public relations
wing for a terrorist group when he says
Palestinian officials the Palestinian
government he's talking about Hamas so
Hamas something blew up we'll get to
that in just a second something did blow
up uh but Hamas then just releases a
statement and he repeats it as if he's
work in PR and actually that's what CNN
is MSNBC is fullon like we're in it with
Hamas but CNN is kind of pretty much
there too that's not journalism and you
know it's not
journalism